we'd begin this morning with new details
on the immigration controversy and
confusion at the border a senior
administration official tells CBS News
that as of last night about 500 children
in custody of Customs and Border
Protection were reunited with their
parents that leaves hundreds more who
are still being held in facilities
managed by the Department of Health and
Human Services that agency has formed a
task force aimed at reuniting those
children with their parents at the White
House yesterday the president hosted
parents of Americans killed by those
here illegally repeatedly pointing out
that they are people who've been quote
permanently separated from their loved
ones we judge Angus at the White House
we just good morning oh good morning to
all of you there certainly are signs of
progress but for all those children who
remain separated from their families
there is not a clear timeline for a
reunion and you're right
President Trump is now trying to shift
the focus to American families who are
impacted by the immigration story this
is what I have left his ashes Sabina
Durden spoke about her son's Dominic who
was murdered by an undocumented
immigrant in 2012 she was among a dozen
families invited to the White House
Friday bringing attention to what the
president calls the other side of the
immigration debate these are the
American citizens permanently separated
from their loved ones because they were
killed by criminal illegal aliens the
emotional event capped off a week of
controversy and confusion resulting in
the administration's zero-tolerance
policy more than 2,300 children were
separated from their families trying to
cross the southern border illegally on
the House floor California Congressman
ted Lieu played audio of children crying
for nearly four minutes leading to a
tense exchange with the presiding
officer at the time representative karen
handel
of georgia will suspend
why are we hiding if the gentleman will
suspend
earlier on Twitter the president had
accused Democrats of telling their phony
stories of sadness and grief hoping it
will help them in the elections you're
gonna have a lot of happy people even
after signing an executive order this
week to stop the separation of families
but he may have killed the chances of
passing a house compromise bill set for
a vote next week tweeting Republicans
should stop wasting their time on
immigration until after we elect more
senators and congressmen women in
November game over
it takes the wind out of sails in what
might have been a fairly productive week
if Congress does not change the law the
president's executive order only allows
the families to be held together for 20
days the Justice Department has asked a
federal judge for an exception to the
rule but if that is not granted the
administration may have to start
separating families again Dana we judge
Aang at the White House thank you